[Music]
sawyer is with us in hickory north
carolina hey sawyer what's up
hey dave how you doing i appreciate you
taking my call sure how can i help
uh well i've got a question for you uh
i've recently it's me trying to make a
decision on something uh so i have a
possible expense uh that i would be
committed to for a year uh it would be
roughly 400 a month so my current home
expenses are a little less than
half of my current take-home pay
that's including you know rent uh the
only thing i owe for is a is a truck
and uh the truck payments are a little
over 400 a month
but
i did that specifically because i'm
trying to get this thing paid off
because i've been i've listened to you
for a long time i don't like being in
debt if i am i don't want to be long how
much do you owe on the truck
uh the truck is about 14 000 left and
your household income is what
uh roughly a month it is uh
right at 2700 a month
pretty expensive truck
yeah it uh i was not at the well the
reason i ended up looking for a truck
was thanks to a girl that rear-ended my
old one
but uh i was originally looking for an
older truck and uh i
really after listening to you for so
long but uh it ended up being that i got
this truck and uh so i've got a little
over three years left to go
uh on it because i got it for four years
and uh
specifically wanted to if i was going to
get something like that i knew i'd have
higher payments but i wanted to get it
paid off as quickly as i could but the
expense that i've got coming up though
that i'm trying to decide on is uh i
told the lady on here that you might
find slightly amusing is uh
there is a hair
type
product online like that's supposed to
try to help you regrow hair
and uh it would be almost another four
hundred dollars a month so
i tried to do my numbers on my current
expenses and so
my expenses per month are roughly a
little over
1200 a month
that's including that truck and that's
also including me putting back for a
retirement fund that i have that's
all of my expenses except for say
how old are you sawyer
27. okay
all right cool
um well you make
38 000
a year 40 000 a year
you have a 14 000 truck and you're
putting money into investments and you
just went and bought the truck on
payments
um and 100 of the things you've
described are things that we tell you
not to do right
yeah
is that right
i mean do you how long have you listened
to the show
uh well for uh for a long time but it
has actually been several years since
i've got to listen again
all right let's read it
let's to be fair to you then let's recap
all right what we would tell you to do
is to become debt free first after you
have one thousand dollars saved do you
have any money in savings
uh yes you're about fifty five hundred
dollars good okay uh you now have one
thousand dollars and you put forty five
hundred on your fourteen thousand dollar
truck and that leaves you ten or nine
thousand five hundred dollars left on
the truck uh you also have an extra job
now and you're going to pay that truck
off in a very very short period of time
when you do that you're going to finish
your emergency oh by the way you stopped
all your long-term investing temporarily
today too
because you're going to work the baby
steps
and then once you're debt free and you
have your emergency fund in place
then if you want to do the care regrowth
program and you want to pay for that
that's when you would do it at that
point
not sure i would do it obviously i
haven't done it